I just turned $50 into over $3500 in 21
days trading this exact future strategy
I'm going to show you. And it only took
me 60 minutes every morning. Over the
years trading futures, I have discovered
three specific times in the markets
where they are very likely to give a
profitable reversal that you can capture
every day. Check out this chart from
today where the market at my time opens
up at 7:30, which is 9:30 Eastern
Standard Time. And so the market I'm
looking at here is the S&P 500 futures
on a one minute chart. You can trade
this on pretty much any major stock
market index. Will follow a lot of these
reversal patterns. And so once the
market opens here, the first reversal
timing I have noticed that consistently
happens is 15 minutes after the market
opens. You can see here at 7:45, 15
minutes after the market opens, my time
is it pretty much bottoms one or two
candlesticks afterwards. And then from
there it has a good bounce. It gives
back this opening move and it comes up
to this area and it hits that second
market reversal timing of 8:00 where it
hits 8:00 which a lot of times some news
can come out or it's just again it's
that opening swing of the market kind of
just whipssawing people back and forth.
This is a lot of the reason why these
market openings and reversal timings
happen and work is because the market
likes to whipssaw when it opens. And so
it pops up here, 8:00 happens, and it
reverses. Now, the third timing is about
an hour and a half after the market
open, which is 9:00 my time or 11:00
normal Eastern Standard Market time.
Now, you can see here it didn't really
reverse the market here. It had a little
bit of a bounce, but at this point, a
lot of the time come this time, if the
market's trending for the day, it's
going to continue trending. So, this
timing isn't as powerful as the first
two. And you can see it kind of blew
past that before it eventually reversed
at some other time. And so that's a big
key with this is if I actually look at
just the previous day before as well is
these aren't always going to work every
time. Look at this day. This is
yesterday. Market opens up at 7:30 and
you can see in the first 30 minutes here
it does absolutely nothing. It's
extremely choppy. And so in this
instance you don't see any movement.
It's unlikely for the market to reverse.
And so you don't want to try and take a
trade. You don't want to just blindly be
trading at these times. But then you can
see it eventually starts to move higher
here. And if we look at 9:00, that
reversal timing is pretty much when it
broke this consolidation that it had and
had a clean reversal down. And so that's
where, you know, sometimes the later
timing can come into play really well.
And so when it comes to trading the
futures markets, the NASDAQ, the ES,
these timings are extreme powerful for
day trading in the morning because what
you can do, I'll show you in a minute,
is you can take a trade off of one of
these levels, risk, you know, a small
amount, however much you're wanting to
risk, get two times your risk,
essentially double your money, and you
can move on with the day, and you can be
done with trading in the first hour of
the market open pretty consistently.
Now, the most important thing when it
comes to looking for these trades and
knowing whether, okay, is it going to
bounce here or is it just going to kind
of fail and continue lower? Is it at a
key spot where the big picture is
actually likely to reverse? That's why
you don't want to just blindly be
reversing at these times. You want the
market to have movement first off
because you know the previous day you
don't want to be trading in that crazy
chop where it just does nothing. But
also you want to see the market at a key
area where you think it's likely to
reverse. And so this is a reversal zone
that I drew from the previous day. And
you can see this the previous day
essentially had a swing high here, some
swing highs here and the market actually
closed here and made a gap which is also
can create a resistance or support
level. And so I kind of drew that across
and said hey I think when the market
maybe retests this it could have a
bounce. And so seeing that align up with
this timing then it has a high chance to
reverse. Now, if you want a
comprehensive guide on the five things I
look for every time I draw a major
support or resistance reversal zone like
one of these, you can download this PDF
guide that I have created for free that
will give you a step-by-step process of
what to look for every time so you can
identify where the major areas of a
reversal are versus where it's likely
to, you know, just blow through that
level and you can save your money and
not enter into a trade. So that's really
valuable resource to get for this. Now I
want to pull up a real example of a
trade I took using the strategy that
looks very similar to what we were just
looking at and using this timing. And so
what we're looking at here is actually a
one minute chart of the NASDAQ futures.
Now again you can trade this on either.
A lot of the times these markets mirror
each other. The reason why I trade one
over the other is I like to go with
which one has better volatility because
volatility is good for trading
especially reversals. And so in this
case you can see at 7:30 my time which
is the US market open market opens here
and just immediately pretty quickly
reverses or continues to move lower. It
does it pretty aggressively in a
fast-paced way. And so for me, what I
see that is, okay, that first keys me
into, hey, we got good movement. And
when there's good movement like this, it
makes it likely to actually reverse. And
so when it comes to 745 right here, I'm
looking at, okay, does it look like it's
going to reverse yet? Is there a reason
for me to think that? Are we at a key
level? It's not there yet, actually,
because at 7:45, the price was right
here. It's not at a support zone yet.
Another key thing is I like to look at
okay what's the current trend and in
this case it was sticking to this
downtrend. It hadn't shown that it was
had clearly broken that yet. And so in
that case I stayed away and let the
market continue lower. And so as the
market started to make a double bottom
here it eventually broke this downtrend.
And really the second step in my major
checklist that I use to get into every
trade. It's really important to have a
consistent plan that you follow every
time when you're trading because it
allows you to consistently repeat it
over time. If you're just blindly
following or reacting to what's the
market's doing and, you know, go with
what you kind of think is going to
happen, you're likely to have
inconsistent trading results over time.
I found that I became profitable when I
started consistently just looking at
these timings every morning, but also
sticking to kind of the same style every
morning and just looking and waiting for
the market to have one of these patterns
show up. I don't take a trade
necessarily every morning, but when I do
take trades, they're highly consistent.
And so the last couple things here is
when the market made this big move down
here, this big red candlestick, and then
had two strong green candlesticks here,
that showed me that this was almost
essentially a final push lower that is
now starting to fail because of how
reversals work a lot of the time is
they'll have a good consistent
downtrend, but when that downtrend
actually breaks, two things can happen.
It can either just reverse right away,
or it'll make an attempt to keep going
lower here, which will fail, and it will
reverse, and it will start a uptrend.
And so, that's when I essentially jumped
in on a trade right here. I'm actually
just going to quickly zoom back in this
recording just to show you really walk
you through the nuts and bolts of
entering in on these trades in this
futures market. And so how I do it is
every time I look to enter in on a
trade, I want to wait for that last
confirmation. So that last confirmation
is for me in this trade was seeing these
two candlesticks and then I wanted to
see how the market reacted to that cuz
sometimes I've seen it where it's come
up and touched essentially the previous
high of where this big bearish
candlestick was and then just continued
lower. And so for me, I'm seeing, okay,
well, it's had this bare candlestick,
which is, you know, it's come up and
then that bare candlestick is showing
it's trying to go lower again. And then
this green candlestick that's forming
right now that just finished, it's
showing that it's breaking above that
previous high. And so I just enter in
essentially above the break of this
high. And so that for me is a a good
momentum play versus getting in on a
limit order. And so that's what's really
important about trading futures and
trading in general is your entry and how
you specifically enter. I've always
found it to be more beneficial to not
try and enter in on a limit order, let's
say down here, or trying to enter in on
a small pullback because those are
really hard to gauge. And also a lot of
the times is if you try and enter in on
this little pullback right here. Well,
it could just be you're entering in on,
you know, when it continues the
downtrend. I find when I enter in on a
stop market order or a break above a
previous high is you're entering in when
that pullback has already happened and
the momentum is in your direction. And
because a lot of these reversals, and I
like to enter in when there's a lot of
volatility, when the momentum switches
like this, even if maybe your entry
price is a little worse in terms of
entering in up here versus entering in
down here, if the move's going to go all
the way up here, it's still a great move
to capture. The whole idea with trading
is you're capturing most of the move.
You don't need to be capturing all of
the move. Like for instance, this chart
right here we were looking at earlier is
entered in here, I would enter in on a
break above this candlestick. And every
time I do, I actually use a tool that
I've created for Ninja Trader that
really helps with futures markets
because it allows you to say, "Hey, I
want to risk, let's say, $725
in a trade or roughly around $700." And
it allows me to say, okay, I want if I
want to risk roughly $700 every trade
and my entry is here and my stop loss is
here, how many contracts do I need to
trade? And that's a hard part about when
you start trading futures is figuring
out how much to risk, especially if you
move this around and the risk changes,
but allows you to target roughly the
same amount every time and it doesn't
grossly over exaggerate how much you're
trading. And then of course you can see
your targets here. And I like to go for
roughly generally two times or three
times my risk. That's a good sweet spot
for trading is when you enter in is
going for that because you don't have to
be right every time and allows you to
take only the best trades and capture
good profitable wins from them. And so
to show you how this trade played out is
I jumped in, put my stop loss below this
big candlestick here because I felt that
hey I think if it comes down here again
it's likely to just continue lower and I
want to get out and the downtrend is you
know even though it's broken this
downtrend here that doesn't mean the
downtrend's over. It could just be
shifting you know to a not as strong or
directional of a downtrend. It's more of
a healthier downtrend with pullbacks.
And so at that point though, I roughly
up here is about that two times profit
limit order. And so you can see here I'm
trading six contracts because that's
what that tool essentially told me to do
based on risking about I think it was
actually I was only risking about $500
on this trade. little smaller size than
my normal, but because the market was
pretty crazy this day, and so I was
risking a smaller amount. But because
there's a high volatility, even though
I'm risking a smaller amount, if the
market moves in my favor pretty far, I
can still get a really nice big
profitable win. And so as this shoots up
here, what I'm looking at is okay, is
there a uptrend here that it's, you
know, as it if it breaks that, I might
want to consider getting out because
same thing with, you know, taking the
reversals over here. If this uptrend
breaks, I think it's likely to reverse.
And so my initial target here is, you
can see I have a resistance zone drawn
up here. So that's what I like to use
for targets as well. Working through
these trades is pingponging between
essentially major resistance and support
zones. I drew kind of an interesting box
here. And what I'm looking for with this
box is I'm thinking, hey, I think the
markets had a nice breakout up here, but
I think it could, even if it breaks this
uptrend that I have drawn, I think it
could pull back somewhere into this
support zone because this is where there
were some previous highs. You got to
give the market wiggle room when it
starts to work out in your favor because
otherwise it's very easy for you to
manage it too quickly and get out too
early. That's a really hard part about
trading as well is jumping into these
trades and having this risk and dollar
amount on the screen and holding off and
not doing anything. You want to have a
plan going into managing your trades too
of okay, when am I going to move my stop
loss to break even? When am I going to
get out of the trade? I roughly change
it between each trade based on what I'm
seeing. But I have, let's say, a rough
flowchart of like if it does this, I'll
do this or if it does that, I'll do
this. And you can see here at this point
I've moved to break even because we're
pretty close to three times my risk
here. I think maybe two times, but it's
moved up to where I'm starting to think,
okay, it's likely it's going to start to
slow down. And so at that point, I break
this up because my thought is, and I
don't recommend doing this right away,
is I want to take off half of my trade
if it's breaks this tight uptrend here.
And so it closes out pretty much half of
this trade right here at an aggressive
stop-loss. I think it closes about $700.
And then at this point, I'm also
thinking, hey, it could start to slow
down here. There is kind of an uptrend,
but this is a nice pullback with a
retest, strong bullish candlestick. And
so, I think if it's going to keep going
higher, it's going to keep going higher.
And if it comes and breaks this new
swing low it made, I'm happy to get out
and I'll close out at about $1,500. Now,
if you're just starting out with trading
futures, I highly recommend getting this
trading platform. It's called Ninja
Trader. You can get it in the link in
description below or this QR code. And
if you want an even more deeper dive
into this strategy where I really go
through more nuts and bolts and details,
check out this video right here.